welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition and it's been a
big week for casting news with us
officially getting the announcement this
morning that Sam Neill Jeff Goldblum and
Laura Dern will be reprising their
iconic roles from the first film for
Jurassic world 3 the actors will be
playing Alan Grant Ellie Sattler and Ian
Malcolm respectively and this feels like
the casting announcement that's been 64
million years in the making
last night at the ArcLight cinemas
Jurassic world event director Colin
Trevorrow announced the news stating
that he's bringing back the original
cast for the third film in the Jurassic
world trilogy and this is of course big
news for fans of the franchise Laura
Dern was brought and staged to a huge
applause and I really wish I could have
been there because yeah I can imagine
this just sent the room wild ever since
the first film we wanted to see a
reunion with these characters and while
some have appeared in other films
sprinkled throughout the series we've
never had them all on screen at the same
time emblem posted this morning on
Twitter that when the whole world has
gone prehistoric he call in the experts
and this definitely feels like the time
to bring out the big guns
Jurassic world 3 is really praying a big
buzz at the moment with a YouTube short
battle at big rock dropping last week
and now this cast is shaping up to be
one of the biggest films in the series
so far naturally the Internet is in
t-rex uproar excuse up on that that bit
rubbish and but yeah the entire thing is
just creating a big buzz and it really
feels like an amazing move by the
producers to send a series off with a
bang Jurassic Park was actually the
first film I ever saw in cinemas and to
see the people that basically made me
fall in love with the medium back
together to take on dinosaurs it just
feels like a big dream come true these
actors did something incredible in the
original film and hopefully they are all
properly utilized going forward now as
of yet we don't know how big that their
roles in the film will be and hopefully
this is far more substantial than the
brief cameo that we got of Jeff Goldblum
from the prior film the Jurassic Park
series needs these three back at the
helm
and this is outstanding news to wake up
to you now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this and if you're
excited for the film comment below and
let me know and if you enjoy this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my breakdown of the news that
Jeffrey Wright will be starring as
Commissioner Gordon in the upcoming Matt
Reeves Batman movie in 2021 I go over
the entire story so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more if you want to come chat to me
about movies TV shows games and comic
books and make sure you follow me into a
dad Definition whitey it's the best way
to get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content so hopefully I see you over
there after this this is the channel for
people who were mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
if you've been the best I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]